mỗi 2 tuần mình phải có hơn mười mấy cuộc họp và mình không
muốn dành rất nhiều thời gian nên mình đã tạo một con agent để
giúp đỡ mình để viết những script và chuẩn bị cho
những cuộc họp này. Bây giờ mình hãy tạo một con agent nha.
xem script này nó có nó có thể làm được gì Thì đó,
đầu tiên bọn nó sẽ opening Nó sẽ bảo là chào mừng mọi người
đến với Sprint Demo Đó, rồi tôi tên là Scrum Master của team Cảm
ơn mọi người đã dành thời gian cho cuộc họp này
Chào các bạn, hôm nay mình sẽ làm video về series AI công việc
văn phòng. Mấy tập trước mình đã dùng một số skill của anh Ivan
để tạo skill cho Office như là Word,
Excel, PowerPoint. Hôm nay mình sẽ cùng các bạn tạo một skill hoặc
là agent. Điều đáng sợ của AI là AI có thể tự viết form
lạnh cho chính bản thân mình, nên mình không phải viết bất cứ thứ
gì, mình hôm nay mình sẽ để AI viết luôn skill hoặc là agent
cho chính nó. Nếu bạn có ý tưởng nào hay,
hãy comment bên dưới, nhớ like, share và subscribe để mình có thêm động
lực làm những video tiếp theo. Sơ qua về mình hiểu về POM.
POM là những quy tắc chung do Ortheopics quy truẩn hóa để hóa để
cho AI có thể đọc hiểu được. Ví dụ như mình tạo một form
thì cái form đấy phải được mọi AI đọc hiểu được từ GPT,
Gemini, Cloud, hoặc là DeepSeek, với mình,
tất cả các đo.def.md file đều là form.
Form tùy mục đích sử dụng, có thể được gọi là skill,
hoặc là agent, hoặc là workflow. Lưu ý,
hôm nay mình sẽ làm demo form ở trên VS Code thay vì
AntiGravity, tại vì mình dùng bản Free với Google để test nên
mình không có nhiều uses hoặc là plans.
sau khi làm xong form mình sẽ test lại trên antigravity
Và một số điều cơ bản,
Antigravity và VS Code là hai IDE giống
nhau đến tận 80%. VS Code là cái cũ cho những
người như mình là software engineer thuần về code.
Còn Antigravity là thuần về AI Driven.
Cho The Demo, hôm nay mình sẽ tóm tắt cuộc họp và tóm
tắt công việc để báo cáo lên manager.
Đó là những công việc mình làm hàng ngày ở công ty.
Let's do it. Thank you. Đây là bảng báo cáo
những công việc mà mình làm hàng ngày ở công ty. Ở công ty
mình là Scrum Master. Với Scrum Master,
công việc của mình của mình sẽ là phải báo cáo sprint planning mình
là người điều phố những cuộc họp về sprint planning là planning những
project đến 2 tuần tới là team sẽ làm những
thứ gì, phải điều phố những công việc như vậy rồi mỗi ngày mình
phải điều phố các cuộc họp của cả team với nhau là mọi người
đã làm gì và làm gì trong ngày hôm đó rồi mình cũng phải
điều phố những cuộc demo với Project
Manager và Manager với cả Leadership là tháng
này hoặc là Spring 2 tuần này team mình đã làm được những gì.
Đó, mình phải người điều phối tất cả những thứ đấy. Rồi Sprint Retro
là cứ mỗi 2 tuần cả công ty,
cả team sẽ ngồi họp với nhau là thứ gì mình đã làm tốt
và làm không tốt trong 2 tuần này. Và mình cũng phải điều phối
những cuộc họp như vậy. Sau đó mình phải điều phối những cuộc họp
về có những project coming up,
có những project đến thì mình phải điều phối về team là xem
làm cách nào để mình có thể biết về những các project
đấy và làm sao để mình có thể lập tịch kế hoạch để hoàn
thiện những project, hoàn thành cái dự án đấy.
Sau đó là PI planning là planning cho 3 tháng,
tương tự như sprint planning. Nhưng mà cái này pending cho 3 tháng Thì
với cuộc họp này mình sẽ phải họp với những leadership là những người
của công ty tổng và những leader của tổng công ty và
manager của mình Đó Và đó là những thứ mà mình phải làm
hàng ngày ở công ty Theo bạn thấy đây thì mỗi 2
tuần mình phải có hơn mười mấy cuộc họp và mình không muốn dành
rất nhiều thời gian nên mình đã tạo một con agent để giúp đỡ
mình để viết những script và chuẩn bị cho những cuộc
họp này. Bây giờ mình hãy tạo một con agent nha.
Đây, mình đã chuẩn bị một cái lệnh sắn cho,
Cái chat của mình. Thì đây, bây giờ mình sẽ bảo cái chat của
mình là Hãy viết một form và form
đấy giúp mình chuẩn bị và báo cáo cho cuộc họp dựa trên những
thông tin mà mình đã có ở đây. Đó,
xong mình sẽ bảo con form ấy viết cho mình. Và mình chạy.
OK, con AI của mình đã tạo cho mình một cái prompt là Scrum
Master Prepare Prompt. Đây là cái form chuẩn bị
cho các cuộc họp và báo cáo Scrum Master dựa trên cái Scrum Guide
là cái guide mà mình vừa đã giới thiệu Đây là và
đây là một số trên hợp bản hướng dẫn,
hướng dẫn tham chiếu, thông tin đầu vào, các loại,
spin, đánh số, thông tin hiện tại rồi này kia nếu có Ok mình
sẽ test cái form này xem nó hoạt động như thế nào nha Bây
giờ mình có cái form này rồi là cách nào để mình sử dụng
Thì bây giờ trước khi những cuộc họp mình chỉ cần đánh tên một
cái form này rồi bảo cho nó làm gì.
Ví dụ như bây giờ mình sẽ chuẩn bị cho cuộc họp demo và
script cho demo.
Đó, rồi mình sẽ chỉ cần bảo nó là Scrum Master Prep This is
the demo Can you make up data Bây
giờ bảo nó là prepare cái script cho mình trước cái Spring Demo Xem
nó làm được gì nha
đến với xem script này nó có nó có thể làm được gì Thì
đó, đầu tiên bọn nó sẽ opening Nó sẽ bảo là chào mừng mọi
người đến với Sprint Demo Đó, rồi tôi tên là Scrum Master của team
Cảm ơn mọi người đã dành thời gian cho cuộc họp này Rồi nó
sẽ, Mình bảo nó tự động lấy những,
tự động tạo những data Nên nó sẽ bảo là ok,
demo này mình sẽ phải làm những gì Đây là kết quả của demo
này như thế nào Đó Rồi những gì mà nó phải làm Bây giờ
hãy để team show thấy mọi người đã làm được những gì đó.
Bạn này và một đồng nghiệp nào đó sẽ lên là demo về cái
dự án đấy. Đó, rồi sau đó rồi nó sẽ bảo là hãy
kiểm tra. Chỉnh tra lại đến Feature 2 là bạn tiếp theo sẽ là
bạn nào, đó. Rồi Feature cuối là bạn nào.
Rồi sau đó là Feedback. Cảm ơn team đã hoàn thành xuất sắc demo
và bây giờ có Feedback từ Manager hoặc là Project Manager sẽ
thế nào. Đó là những script mà mình hay tạo.
Mỗi ngày ở công ty trước khi cuộc họp mình chỉ dành 5 phút
để mình tạo script và đến cuộc họp mình sẽ follow script
để đọc lên. Hãy thử với AntiGravity xem
nó có thể làm được không. Đây
là mình đang có AntiGravity. Để mình thử Anti-Gravity với cái Squam
Master Form này nha,
Agent này. Đó. Mình bảo Accom Squam
Master đấy.
Scrum Master. Đó.
This Demo. Đó. Để xem,
Để xem AI có,
Nó sẽ biết cho mình script như thế nào để mình chuẩn bị cho
demo của mình. Nó sẽ Ok,
nó đã hoàn thành xong. Hãy đọc qua xem AI đã
làm agent này của mình như thế nào nha.
Đây là một số thông tin về, Đây chỉ là giả định thôi,
chỉ là mockup data thôi, đó. Rồi thông tin về cuộc họp.
Mở đầu như nào 5 phút, cập nhật bối cảnh của sprint,
rồi demo sản phẩm, thu thập feedback từ manager,
thảo luận rủi ro và tổng kết và đóng cuộc họp đó.
Mở đầu sẽ chào mừng tất cả mọi người. Mình là các bạn. Cảm
ơn Product Manager và Stakeholder và toàn thể team đã dành thời gian buổi
sáng. Mình sẽ làm như thế này bằng tiếng Anh.
Và đó là con agent mà mình đã build ở công ty.
Với mình, tiếng Anh của mình không giỏi so với những người bản địa.
Nhưng với AI đã giúp mình tự tin hơn và bước từng bước từng
bước bước ra khỏi vùng an toàn của mình. Hy vọng với bạn cũng
vậy. Thank you for watching.